and a cesarean delivery generally
known as a caesarean section is a
surgical procedure in which
incisions are made in
a woman's abdomen and uterus to deliver a
baby some caesarean sections are planned
however often the need for the
procedure becomes apparent after
the  onset of labor when
abnormal conditions make a
natural delivery unsafe for the
mother or her baby common indications
for cesarean delivery include
placenta praevia dystocia and
fetal distress distance or
prolonged nonprogressive labor may occur
when  the baby's head does not fit through
the birth canal or the baby's body is
in an unfavorable position
such as perpendicular to
the birth canal or breech such
as breech placenta
previa occurs when the placenta
is  in a low position and
partially or
completely obstructs the cervical opening the
sufrimi  Fetal distress occurs when the
health of the baby is in
imminent danger, usually due to
insufficient blood flow through the
placenta or cord,
and fetal distress can occur
when the placenta separates from the wall
of the uterus before delivery  or the
umbilical cord is compressed or strangulated other
conditions that may require a
cesarean delivery include
multiple births large tumors of the uterus
genital herpes or other infections or
medical problems such as
high blood pressure or uncontrolled diabetes
the doctor may use the nest tracing and
a  fetal heart monitor to
help you decide whether or not the baby will be delivered
by cesarean section when a cesarean delivery is necessary
prepare you for surgery if it has not already
been placed have an
IV started and a catheter inserted
into your  the bladder to drain urine
in the operating room you will be
anesthetized to in most cases
is administered  epidural anesthesia
to numb the lower part of the
body however sometimes a
general anesthetic will be used
the doctor will start by making an
incision in the abdomen it will be a
vertical incision just below the navel to
the top of the pubic bone or
more often a horizontal incision
in  crosswise and just above
the pubic bone this incision
is often called a
bikini incision then the doctor will make a
second incision in the lower part
of the uterus once the uterus is opened
your doctor will break the amniotic sac if
it is still intact  the baby will be delivered the
time from the
initial abdominal incision to delivery
is usually five minutes
then the doctor will think and cut the
umbilical
cord carefully remove the placenta and
saturate the uterus and abdomen well
this usually takes around 45
minutes  Usually the
hospital stay after a postpartum  c-section
is 3-5 days during this time it
will be recommended that your lover sleep
when the baby is asleep and get out of
bed often although most
patients are able to care for their
newborn baby after the procedure
full recovery may
take 6-8 weeks the scar will
lighten as it heals